PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: All right,
so this lecture we
talked about fold
and one cut, two
methods and a little bit
about polyhedron flattening,
so most of the questions
are about fold and one cut.
I'll stick to that.
First question is, is
there an equal software
for doing fold-and-cut now?
And the answer is yes,
there's some software.
Maybe not the coolest possible
yet, but it's getting there.
There's two pieces of software.
One is from Final Project after
this lecture was given, 2010.
And another one is in
SourceForge project
called JOrigami, or J Origami.
Both are written
in Java, I believe.
I have this one.
This is the swan, which
you've seen before.
I have it here.
We can try it out.
It's not online yet, because
it could use some improvements,
but it's already pretty cool.
So you can take something
like the angelfish here,
and if you like,
it has an editor
so you can move
your polygon around.
And you can say, OK, please
give me the straight skeleton,
first straight skeleton only,
and it will update on the fly,
and gives you some nice
intuition about how that works.
I know that looks weird
that it goes up that way,
but it is correct,
because it's bisecting
this edge and some
edge, this one I guess.
They meet out here, and
then you go that way.
So you can play with
that, and then you
can add in the
perpendiculars too.
Takes a little bit
longer, so the refresh
may not be as immediate.
But it works.
It's really complicated behavior
in there, some spiraling in,
spiraling out, but it's
fairly well-behaved.
Here's one of the simpler
spiraling examples.
This one is stable under
perturbation more or less.
You move the vertices
all a little bit.
They should continue spiraling.
It looks like that one is
a little bit degenerate.
So we'll go around, and as you
go get bigger and bigger pieces
of paper, you'll get
more and more creases.
I should mention, you can
add new vertices as well
and draw polygon.
You can delete edges.
I'm holding all sorts
of crazy modifier keys
to make this happen,
but it does work.
The one other thing you
can do is snap to a grid.
This is probably hard to see,
but there's a square grid
underneath.
If you hold down Alt, it
snaps to a square grid.
I have one other
example I've prepared.
It has save and load,
which is pretty cool.
And this example is one
of the dense instances.
Although this one has
rational multiples,
so it doesn't
actually go forever.
Because I drew it
on the grid so that
could get all the
horizontal and verticals.
And you can see in
particular it stops
here, because at some
point it gives up
in reflecting perpendiculars,
says that's enough.
It won't draw anymore.
So it's fairly
robust in that sense.
Occasionally it's using
some straight skeleton
code they did not write,
and it has some issues
when you have really
degenerate situations,
which they tried to mitigate.
But occasionally
it's not perfect.
But there are lots
of possible follow
on projects to this work,
improving the user interface.
Actually putting it
on the web for people
to play with, I think,
would be super cool.
Alternatively, could port
it to JavaScript-- right now
it's in Java-- and make it
even more accessible run
on iPhones and things like that.
Still, one of the questions
I've posed in lecture
was, can you make a
nice interface that
would let you
force degeneracies,
make like in-- I think the swan
has instances of this, where
you'd like more than three
skeleton edges to come together
at a point.
Here they almost do.
It would be nice to be able
to say, and for it to snap
to a position where many
things come together.
Because that, in general,
reduces number of creases
substantially.
You could also try to
compute the folded state.
That would be another
interesting project
based on what we're
going to talk about
in a little bit,
folding the underlying
structure of corridors.
And then you can computer
a crease pattern.
And there you have
various choices,
and that lets you throw
away some of these creases.
Like this is much messier
than the swan crease
pattern that's on my
web page, because you
don't need all these folds.
If you choose the
right subset of folds
you can save a lot of time.
So, still lots of cool
projects to do here.
It'd be great to get
this software online,
but that's its current state.
Next question is, what
about odd degree vertices?
This is actually a
pretty natural question.
Even degree vertices seem nice
because you can kind of-- well,
it relates to a page
that I didn't really
talk very much about
in the lecture,
but it was in the lecture notes,
this idea of a side assignment.
So in general, if you have
something like a swan,
there's the inside of the
swan, the outside of the swan,
and generally you have
a bunch of regions.
And for each region
you'd like to know
is it above the cut line
or below the cut line?
If you imagine the cut
line as horizontal.
And in general,
the side assignment
would specify, do I want
my region above or below?
And you could do
whatever you want.
Now with even degree
vertices, this is great.
You could just alternate
around and say, above,
below, above, below.
With odd degree
vertices, you can't,
so you're going to
have two regions that
are adjacent to each other which
are both above or both below.
So what does that mean?
It means it's a little
bit hard to cut.
And there's actually
two models of cuts.
There's scissor cuts-- which are
in particular what the question
poser had in mind,
and probably what
you might have had in mind in
general-- where the cut you're
going to make separates material
from above and below the line.
So this is the cut line here.
And it'd be really nice if you
had material on both sides,
because that's usually how
scissors work, they tear apart
material.
An alternative is that you
have a mathematical cut.
And a mathematical cut can
cut right along a crease line.
So it could be you
have two polygons,
there's a fold here between
them, and you can cut right
along that line.
Maybe I shouldn't draw scissors.
Imagine a laser beam which
can zap right along the line,
so there's no material on the
left side of the line, just
material on the
right, but yet it
separates the two
things on the right.
So we call that
mathematical cut,
because it is the natural
definition mathematically.
You're erasing a line.
But practically it's
a little hard to do.
So scissor cuts are also nice.
This is a more
restrictive model.
This is general model.
So what I was talking
about in lecture,
implicitly use
mathematical cuts.
And that's when you could
make anything with one cut.
But, it would be nice to get
scissor cuts when possible.
And when possible
is basically when
you have even degree
at every vertex.
And one fun example of
that is checkerboard.
This is actually
an old magic trick.
You have a piece of usually
tissue paper, so it's
really thin, pre colored
as checkered squares,
both sides matching.
And you can fold this,
because every vertex here
has degree 4, so
even degree, you
can assign the
black squares to be
on one side or the
blue squares to be
one side, the white squares
to be on the other side.
And so you could make one cut
and simultaneously cut out
all the white squares and
all the black squares which
is kind of cool.
This is old, decades old.
So in general, you can do
something with scissor cuts.
Or scissor cuts are going
to be possible if and only
if you can find
a side assignment
that sort of alternates between
above and below the cut line.
Meaning when you have two
regions that are adjacent,
you don't want them both
to be above and below.
You'd like one to be
above, one to be below.
And this is what's called a face
2-coloring in planar graphs.
You want to color the faces,
the regions of your graph,
with two colors such that
no two adjacent cells have
the same color, no two adjacent
faces have the same color,
and that turns out to
be equivalent to having
all vertices of even degree.
So this is why that question
was asking about odd degree,
because indeed with scissor
cuts, you can't do odd degree.
There is a fun fact, though,
that relates these two things.
So if you have even
degree like polygons,
which is typical case, scissor
cuts should be possible.
Mathematical cuts
can do everything.
What if I have something
that has odd degree vertices,
but I still want to
use scissor cuts?
Well then, it turns out two
cuts are enough, pretty much.
That if you have, I'll call it
a 2-edge-connected planar graph,
equals the union
of two even graphs.
I should say even subgraphs.
It doesn't much matter.
So there's one
exception, which is,
if you have an edge in
your desired set of cuts,
that partitions the
graph into two parts.
So if you could delete an
edge and disconnect the graph
into more parts, there's
no hope of decomposing this
into even graphs.
I think.
Should check that.
But as long as you
do not have such,
these are called
bridges, typically.
So bridges are forbidden.
If you have no
bridges, then you're
at what's called a
2-edge-connected planar graph.
And then you can
decompose your graph
into two parts, each
of which is even.
So you could fold,
make one straight cut,
and get one even graph,
fold, make once straight cut,
get the other even graph.
Good luck folding it the
second time if it decomposed.
But in theory at least,
with two scissor cuts,
you can make anything
that doesn't have bridges.
So that's just kind of an aside.
Some graph theory that
tells you a little bit more
about what you can
do with two scissor
cuts-- pretty much everything.
Any more questions about that?
So that was odd degree vertices.
Next questions are about
folding and how exactly-- so
I kind of briefly sketched the
proof for linear corridors,
how you would fold
or how you would
prove that this
thing actually folds.
This is the skeleton
method first.
We'll go to
disk-packing afterwards.
So how do you convert a set of
linear quarters into a tree?
Then once you have
that correspondence,
how does trees
folding flat relate
to corridors folding flat?
And so I redrew this figure to
make it a little bit clearer.
So this is one of the images
in the textbook where I just
face colored, in this case with
three colors, the corridors.
Those are the regions
of constant width
bounded by perpendiculars.
This is for making a turtle.
That sort of doesn't
really matter.
And this is the
corresponding tree.
And this is the folded
state of this blue guy
here between B and C.
And to really illustrate
what's going on here,
I folded this thing.
It's tricky to fold, let's say.
And I added a few paper
clips to make it really stay.
But if you hold it right, which
is a little bit challenging,
the projection of this
structure is exactly this tree.
Maybe let me show
you some examples.
Out here, for example,
this flap is labeled A B,
so it corresponds to this flap.
And it corresponds to the
material here between A and B.
And this A part is at the very
tip here, and attached to this
is this guy.
That would be this
unlabeled pink edge,
which corresponds to this one.
It's unlabeled, because it goes
off to infinity in principle.
So this would just keep going.
This one turns
around right here.
Then there's this edge,
this bit of material.
Sorry, it's probably easier
for you to see from that side.
And that corresponds
to this BC part,
which is exactly this folding.
And if I laser cut
or even scissor
cut down these two
lines, and just
cut out that little
folded part, it
would look exactly like this.
So conversely, I was sort
of begging the question
by assuming I could
fold this thing,
if you don't know how
to fold this thing,
you can go on the
reverse direction
and figure out how to
fold it by first modeling
these corridors as a tree.
How do you do that?
It's just like in
the tree method,
going from crease pattern
from the tree method
to the shadow tree.
Except there, we were given
the shadow tree as input.
Here, we have to compute it.
But it's like what you
solved in the problem set.
Is it one or two?
For each of these corridors,
it has fixed width,
so you make an edge
of that length.
It's not quite
drawn to scale here.
This has been scaled up by
roughly a factor of two.
So this length
becomes this length.
And you label it the same thing.
This set of connecting
component of perpendiculars A
goes to that point.
The connected component
of perpendiculars here,
this thing which
branches, all of that
is B. It's like a hinge
in the tree method.
So that's going to be a hinge
between this flap and two
other flaps, whatever
touches the B perpendicular.
So there's this pink one,
and there's the cyan one.
Cyan one is here.
It's attached to whatever
C is attached to.
so here's C.
It branches off
here, bounces around.
All that's C, and it's adjacent
to the blue thing we just did.
The yellow and the pink-- that's
this yellow and this pink--
connecting to D and G, and
so on through the thing.
So it's actually really
easy to map from here
to the tree, just every
corridor maps to an edge.
Every connected component
of the perpendicular graph
maps to a point.
And this is the projection.
It will always look
exactly like this.
You'll be able to
independently manipulate
each of these
corridors as a flap.
And individually it's pretty
easy to fold each corridor.
It just looks like
this accordion thing.
So the faces will be stacked
linearly in order from
back to front, and
be really clean.
They'll all line up in
this nice vertical strip.
So that's easy to
prove it exists
from sketching the proof now.
And then all you have to
do is attach them together.
So basically first you take this
tree view, you fold it flat.
Here, I can fold it flat just by
collapsing the top and bottom.
Then I replace
each of these edges
with one of these
vertical accordion strips.
And then I just need to
check that at each vertex
I can actually attach
everything that
needs to attach without
getting crossings.
So that's the one
part of the proof
I'm not going to show you,
because it's kind of tedious.
But basically, because
the structure was planar,
because it came
from one sheet, you
can show there's not going
to be any crossings there.
All of these layers,
each of these edges
expands to be many
layers, and the layers
will nicely connect together.
So that's the sketch
of that proof.
Any questions?
This is for just linear
corridors, not circular ones.
OK.
Cool.
Next question is
about the bad example
that makes a dense set of
creases that completely fills
the plane, and therefore
is completely unfoldable.
And the question was,
is it really unlikely
or is actually very
likely that this happens?
And there are two
things going on.
Here's the example,
again, from the textbook.
So it's got, the dark blue
is the desire cut graph,
then the black lines are
the straight skeleton,
and then the dash
lines are the beginning
of the perpendiculars.
And the point was to
make this corridor width
verses this corridor
width verses this quarter
width versus this
corner width, make
those all irrational
multiples of each other.
And then as this thing spirals
around, it never finishes.
It never hits itself.
And so it just keeps going.
I think this is where this
one's currently going.
And so the question is,
well, irrational multiples
are actually very common.
If you, for example, randomly
perturb all these vertices
and you measure the
sizes of those corridors,
with probability 1, they
will be irrational multiples
of each other,
because irrationals
are much more common
than rational numbers.
And that's true.
But the other thing that
this example requires
is this outer boundary.
We need that none of
these perpendiculars
can escape out to infinity.
If they do, they
won't stay in there.
Eventually, if there's
a tiny, tiny gap here,
if these guys didn't
quite match up, eventually
because this thing is dense,
it will find that little gap
because it has positive length.
When it finds the
gap, it's going
to spiral around and
around and around
and go out to infinity instead
of being trapped inside.
So the unlikely
thing in this example
is actually this
outer pink polygon,
that the perpendicular
coming out this way
bounced around,
did lots of things,
and eventually hit
the same vertex.
That's actually unlikely.
Definitely in this
example and in general
we claim that we do not get
cycles of perpendiculars
except in one kind
of scenario, which
I guess I could draw
in the software.
Let's try it.
So whenever you have a vertex
of degree more than two,
so let's do something like that.
Little too far away.
So let me just add a
little guy like this.
And this a little closer.
It's got a lot of spiraling.
Let's make it a little
bit cleaner here.
It's actually kind
of degenerate,
but the point is, if-- here
I have three cut edges.
I've kind of made them roughly
equal so this doesn't get huge,
but in general, if you have
any straight skeleton vertex
and you reflect it'
around these bisectors,
you will always come back
to where you started.
So this requires that
each of these angles
is strictly convex, so this is
why you need at least three cut
edges to come together here.
But once you have
at least three,
you'll always cycle around.
You'll always come back
to where you started.
It actually happens again here.
This guy cycles
around and comes back.
So that's-- well, sorry, that
one's actually a little bit
special because of what
I did with the dragging.
In general, it's going
to be more like this.
It's a little hard to see.
What's going on here is that
this innermost guy cycles
around, indeed,
but everyone else
spirals around and keeps going.
So that's actually
the perpendicular.
It comes from here
and goes that way,
and then it spirals around.
It hasn't finished yet,
but it would actually
spiral all the way
out to infinity.
So the claim is, in general,
the-- this is conjecture.
With probability 1, if you
randomly perturb the vertices
slightly, the only cycles of
perpendiculars that you get
are around a single vertex.
So something like
this example, which
we saw where there is a straight
skeleton edge here, here,
and then this guy-- I guess I
should draw the skeleton edges.
It's a good test of
how accurate I drew it,
because I know if
this is perpendicular,
and this is perpendicular,
this will always come back
to its starting point.
It's just property
of reflections.
Basically, because we
satisfy Kawasaki here,
this must be true because these
are bisectors of these guys.
So this has to happen.
The claim is, that's the
only situation it happens.
And if this is all
that happens, you
can prove there's no density,
and in fact, it folds flat.
So this is the good case.
Unfortunately, when
we make real examples,
we like degeneracies
because they
reduce the number of folds.
So the theory says, avoid
degeneracies Let's perturb
things slightly, then
it's guaranteed to fold.
But in practice, you want
to add degeneracies, just
carefully so that you
don't get dense behavior
like the weird
example I showed you.
So that's clarification why
we think this does not happen.
Or, sorry, why we think with
probability 1 things are good.
But sadly we can't prove this.
Maybe we'll work on it in
the open problem session.
I think it's tractable, I
just haven't worked on it
in a long time.
Questions?
OK.
So, right.
The claim is if you
perturb this example,
everybody will escape out to
infinity like in the spiral.
OK.
So I think this is the end
of the skeleton method,
but before we go on, I
want to show some examples.
So problem set-- we have up to
four [INAUDIBLE] later today.
One of the questions is
design your own folding cut,
and draw it.
So you probably want to draw
it into a program like Inkscape
or Adobe Illustrator.
It has good snapping, so you can
find intersections and things
like that, and compute
angular bisectors
as in ruler and compass.
And these are some examples
from 2010, same question.
There are lots of
them, but I chose
three that are
particularly cool.
This one has a line
of symmetry, you
get a fish bone
by [? Ji, ?] who's
a Ph.D. student
in the media lab.
This is by
[? Sarah Eisenstadt ?],
who's a Ph.D. student in CSAIL
working on folding things.
Witch's hat is pretty
cool, pretty fairly simple.
You have to fold your examples.
It can't be too complicated.
And then Jason [? Ku ?], who
we saw the guest lecture by
wasn't sufficiently impressed
by my jack o' lantern,
so he made a really
complicated one and folded it.
So those are some
inspiration points.
And I thought I'd show
you a magic trick which
is one of the sources
for inspiration
for the fold and
one cut problem.
So, a piece of paper.
So this is a magic
trick of unknown origin.
It was described
by Martin Gardner,
I think, probably in
the '60s, and then
the book appeared in the '90s.
And it's a story
of two politicians,
and let's just be generic.
Let's say one politician was
very much liked by the people,
and the other politician
was disliked by the people.
Imagine a simple world
where it was so simple.
And by a freak accident,
both politicians
die at the same time.
And they both happen
to be Christians,
so they go to the
gates of Heaven.
That's how the story goes.
And arrive at the
gates of Heaven.
I guess Saint Peter's
the keeper of the gates,
and Saint Peter
says, well not just
anyone can get into heaven.
You have to have a ticket.
And the good politician
being liked by the people
has a ticket, which
he folds flat.
And the bad politician
has no ticket.
So the bad politician
says, well you know,
we've had our
disagreements, but maybe you
could put in a good
word to Saint Peter
or do something to help me out.
I hear Heaven's a nice place.
Maybe we could go
there together,
resolve our
differences, whatever.
So the good politician, having
a ticket and a pair of scissors
like any respecting
politician, takes his ticket
and makes one
complete straight cut.
And it's going to
get a lot of pieces,
so I've got to be,
hold this carefully.
So, put that down.
And he hands all these
pieces to the bad politician,
says there you go.
The bad politician has
no idea what they're for,
so he hands them to Saint Peter.
Saint Peter starts
unfolding the pieces, says,
I wonder what shapes I get.
I hear there's a cool
problem about this.
So it's a little hard
to do without a table.
So I'm going to have
to use the board.
First, we get the letter H. Then
we get-- put these down here.
Then we get the letter E. OK?
Then we get letter
L, and the letter L.
And if it was on a
table, I'd arrange it,
and clearly Saint
Peter's not happy,
and the bad politician
gets sent straight to hell.
The good politician hung
on to one piece cleverly,
and his ticket is still
more or less intact,
and he gets into heaven.
That's the magic trick.
It's very simple folding.
I've known this, memorized
this even, for years.
And you get exactly
those pieces.
So pretty cool.
Of course, from a
mathematical standpoint,
it's a little unsatisfying.
Because, come on, use
three pieces for the H,
three pieces for the E.
Surely you could do better.
And from a rectangle, you
can kind of do better.
It's a little awkward
because the pieces
are not all the same size,
but is one scissor cut
because all the vertices
are even degree.
You cut it, and you get
all these pieces, which
if I were more
practiced at this,
I could immediately pick
out which one's the H. OK,
I'll just do them out of order.
Here is the cross.
Well, kind of a cross.
Not quite perfect
proportions, but good enough.
This is the letter E. This one's
actually more impressive when
you don't have a table, because
you can't tell that they're all
different sizes.
The letter E. We've got the
letter-- these look like L's.
And they're small
L's, but there you go.
They're different orientations.
And then I've got the
letter H. There you go.
OK.
So that's our new and improved
version using universality
of folding cut.
So it gives you some idea
of A, where folding cut
came from in recent times,
is the magic community.
I mentioned Harry Houdini
did some tricks, and Gerald
[? Low ?], but there's a
bunch of these tricks around,
and kind of cool.
So the checkerboard trick
and the previous hell trick.
So those are some examples.
Now we move onto the
disk-packing method.
So I have one
question about this,
which is, how exactly do we
go from the disk-packing to--
yeah, cool proof,
though, cool proof, bro.
So how do we go from
the disk-packing
to the decomposition into
triangles and quadrilaterals.
So I thought I'd just
review this slide.
We start with our graph.
We offset it by
some tiny epsilon.
That's to get things
off the line, basically.
Then we do this disk-packing.
And remember roughly how
the disk-packing works.
We put some disks at
each of the centers.
Here, it's a little awkward
because of the offset,
but you put one at each
of these four corners.
Also the corners of
the piece of paper.
Why not?
Then you also pack small
enough disks along the edge,
so that you cover the edge
by diameters of the disks.
I do that the same
on all the sides.
Basically, you try
to put a big one in,
but if that big one intersects,
you decompose it into half.
That's how the algorithm works.
So now you've covered the
vertices and the edges,
but you may have
big gaps like this,
too many sides on this gap.
And so then you
just greedily put
the largest disk you
can in those gaps
until all you're left
with in these yellow gaps
are triangles and
quadrilaterals,
or three-sided gaps
and four-sided gaps.
And then all we do is
draw this red graph
by putting a vertex at
the center of each disk.
That's what the
question was about.
And then whenever
two disks touch,
we call this kissing disks
for historic reasons,
because they're just
barely touching I guess,
at their lips.
Got a lot of lips for disks.
At least we're in flat land.
So then whenever
they touch, we draw
the edge between
the two centers.
So that decomposes this
piece of paper into parts,
and because the gaps
are three sides,
those will correspond to
triangles, or four sides,
those will correspond
to quadrilaterals.
So that's all.
And then we put
rabbit ears in here,
and line universal quad
molecules in there,
and it folds flat.
It will align all
of the red edges
plus these black
edges on the outside,
and it will align all
these inner red edges
with these black
edges, and then we
do the sync folds
that we mentioned.
And that will get one of these
out of the way of the other,
and we'll end up aligning
just these cut edges.
So that's a quick
review of that method.
So one question is, how
do you allocate the disks.
Is there sort of a best way?
And I guess there could
be several measures.
Maybe you don't want
really tiny disks,
because that tends to
lead to very tiny folds.
But the standard measure here
is how many disks do you need,
because that will reduce
the number of folds.
So can you minimize
the number of disks,
and in general,
it's known roughly
how many disks you need.
And the algorithm
I just told you
achieves that number of disks.
So first I'll give
you the number.
Number of disks is
proportional to the integral--
I didn't say it
was the easy bound,
but it is the right answer.
OK, there's a lot
of notation in here,
and this one you
should definitely not
know unless you've taken a
computational geometry class.
Even then, you probably
wouldn't know it.
It's not that common.
It mostly comes up in
meshing and disk-packing,
so it's pretty specific.
It's called local feature size.
And this is if,
once I define it,
it is actually fairly
intuitive, this bound.
Local feature size
at X. So we're
imagining some kind
of polygon here.
And at every point
of the polygon--
let's look at a
vertex here-- but it
works for any point
along the boundary.
Actually maybe not
even on the boundary,
but we're interested
here-- this notation del p
is the boundary of the polygon.
So this is del p.
That just means edges and
vertices, all of those points.
So we take some point
X on the boundary,
and we look at the
smallest disk centered
at that point that
touches another feature.
So that's the feature size.
Features here are
edges of the polygon.
That's all we have.
Now of course, no matter what
size disk, you hit this feature
and you hit this feature,
so those don't count.
Those are incident features.
So in general, it is
the smallest radius disk
that hits a non incident feature
on incident feature, which
is an edge.
So here, as soon as
the disk gets this big,
it hits this edge.
And so the local feature
size is this radius.
In general, for every point,
you can draw some size disk.
So over here, it's going
to be a little bit bigger.
You can maybe get up to here.
Actually, I guess it
should be non-adjacent.
That was going to be
a little bit awkward.
I also don't want
to count this edge,
because if I'm right here, the
feature size is super tiny,
and I don't want
LFS ever to be 0.
So you also have to skip
the adjacent edges, which
means local feature
size of this point
is going to be more like--
hard to draw circles--
it's going to be more
like that distance.
That's when you hit a
non-adjacent feature, sorry.
So you have to exclude
this edge that you're on
and the two adjacent
ones, otherwise
this definition
doesn't quite work out.
So then you measure
this for all points.
There's infinitely
many, of course,
continuum along the boundary.
That's the integral over
X in the boundary of P.
And you take 1 over the
local feature size of X,
and you integrate that for
all X. It gives you a number,
and it turns out, some
constant times that number
is the right answer.
The algorithm I achieve,
which I described,
which is put the biggest disk
you can or divide in half
if you can't will get within
a constant factor of the best
possible bound of all
possible to disk-packings.
So this is pretty much known.
You get within a constant factor
of the optimal disk-packing
if you're counting disks.
Not a great number.
I can't say they're N
disks or N squared disks,
because you just can't do that.
If you have a piece of
paper and some really long--
here's your cut graph.
Doesn't quite go to the
ends, though-- then you've
got to have a tiny
disk here, and that's
going to require you to
have a bunch of disks.
Even though this has constant
size, you're going to need,
I don't know how
many disks here.
Especially if your
paper's really narrow,
you're going to
need a lot of disks.
That's the best you can
hope for disk-packing.
I actually brought a
little example of something
like that where
your goal is just
to cut out a single segment
in the middle of the paper.
This is to illustrate
odd degree vertices.
These are degree 1 vertices,
and you might think,
wow, it's impossible for me
to cut this thing without,
I don't know, just cutting.
I could cut with my X-ACTO
knife from here to here.
If I want to make a
complete straight cut,
you can fold it like this.
This is what the skeleton
method would give you.
Fold it like this, and
then you use your laser
to cut right along the line.
With scissor cuts,
it's not so bad, right?
I cut slightly in.
It's pretty much
cutting along the line.
Just not quite.
I made a tiny mistake.
So I cut off a line,
slightly thicker line,
and I get my slit in the paper.
So mathematical cuts
are not really that bad.
You just are cutting a
slightly larger version
than the single slit
that you wanted to make.
You just have to
cut very carefully.
OK.
That was number of disks.
Next question is, how does all
this relate to the tree method?
This is kind of a neat question.
Both methods, skeleton method
and the disk-packing method
relate to the tree
method in different ways.
I thought I would
talk about that.
So first, let's compare
the disk-packing method
which we just talked
about to the tree method.
Both of them use
universal molecules.
This one only uses
universal molecules
for triangles and quads.
We know in general,
the universal molecule
works for any convex polygon.
This is an example
of a pentagon.
And it works.
It has a gusset to get
the tree lengths right.
Here we use gussets to kind
of get the tree lengths right.
As you may recall, we
want the perpendiculars
to go to the disk kissing
points, those tangencies.
Because then they
align with the others,
and then we never
get the perpendicular
spiraling or doing
other bad things.
So the number of creases becomes
proportional to the number
of disks.
The number of disks
is this messy thing.
So that's that.
Let's see, what else?
Here, we only use disks.
Over here, we could
just use disks,
but there's also the
ability to use rivers,
so this is more general in
that we can do bigger polygons
than' just quads, and we can
do rivers, not just circles.
Here, the input, though, is a
tree with specified lengths,
and it's actually NP-hard to
place the disks correctly.
We proved that last time.
Over here, the
input is a polygon.
It's already been embedded
on the sheet of paper.
There's no really hard
decisions here except you
have to fill the
paper with disks.
But that's not so hard.
So you can do this
in polynomial time.
Polynomial and even,
almost, roughly this time.
Times a log factor.
You can find
displacement of disks.
So that's not too hard,
whereas over here, it's
NP-hard to place a disk,
optimally at least.
Find a displacement
you could do.
So basically the
inputs differ, and it's
using the same
backbone or the same,
what do you call it, front end.
The same back end, I
suppose, after we've
decomposed into a
bunch of molecules,
you just fold the molecules
and you're basically done.
Here we have to do
some syncs at the end,
but it's using it for
different purposes.
Otherwise they're very similar.
And indeed, this is
inspired by that.
OK, so that was the
disk-packing method.
Then there's the
straight skeleton method.
These look much more
different, but in fact, they
are quite related.
If you do fold-and-cut
on a convex polygon,
it gives you roughly
the universal molecule,
just with no gussets.
So here, neither one is
more general than the other.
The universal molecule
is more general
in that it has
gussets, which lets
it control the tree
topology you get and control
the lengths you get in the tree.
Over here, we saw the
tree just happens.
You can't control the tree.
The shadow tree is just a tool
to prove that it falls flat,
but you can do non
convex polygons, which
is much more general
than convex polygons.
So they each have their
own unique claims to fame.
A natural question is,
can you combine them.
And in fact, you can.
And this was, you may remember
a bunch of lectures ago--
I think class four
or so-- I showed
this slide of the meat
of origami design secrets
volume two, or the
second edition, rather.
There's tree theory,
which we talked about.
There was a box pleating tree
theory which we briefly showed.
And there's this more general
thing called polygon packing,
and this is in some
sense the fusion
of straight skeleton
method of fold-and-cut,
basically the straight
skeleton, plus tree theory.
And this is done jointly between
Robert Lang and the domains.
And here's an example
of what it looks like.
It's a little hard to see
here, but I will point out
if you look at the blue lines,
which are the cut lines-- here,
of course, they're
the active paths.
This guy is non convex.
And if you look at the
red stuff in there,
it is exactly the straight
skeleton of that polygon.
So those red lines are
the straight skeleton
of this blue thing.
So there you go.
I've got the fold-and-cut
straight skeleton
being used in that setting.
You've got perpendiculars
all over the place, which
is an annoying feature
of the skeleton method.
It is inherited by this method.
And if you look at something
like this rectangle.
It's convex, but
you have gussets.
This is a gusset, this is
a gusset, gusset, gusset.
It's a little hard to
see, but we basically
split the rectangle into
this rectangle, this square,
this rectangle, this
square, this rectangle.
So this is really the
fusion of the two.
It's not yet been
mathematically formalized,
because we're first proving
that the tree method works.
Then we will
finally get to this.
But if you want these slightly
more informal but practical
version, read Oragami Design
Secrets and it will explain
all the different
cases and what we
believe is a correct algorithm.
We just haven't proved
all the cases yet.
And you can use it to design
cool things in the box pleating
setting and get more efficient
than if you required rectangles
or some convex shape.
Cool.
So that's that.
What else do we have?
I have one-- almost done-- one
cool open question posed by you
is, what if instead of
cutting with a straight line,
I cut with a constant
curvature line?
So a piece of a circular arc.
Then, of course,
the things I get
will have circular
arc boundaries,
but can I get any
circular arc boundary
with that fixed curvature?
Or are there limitations?
And at first I thought
the answer is clearly yes,
but I do wonder about
situations like this.
Can you align these
two by folding?
I haven't thought
about it enough
to be sure, but
not totally sure.
Whereas if I have things like
this, I think this is good.
I mean, I could fold
here, and in general, I
could just kind of
pretend there's a segment.
And the segment I saw fold
and cut on the segments,
and that will also
align the circular arc.
That won't work
in general, but I
feel comfortable if they
have the same orientation,
it looks good.
When they flip
orientations, I'm not sure.
So a neat problem
to think about.
And one final thing
is about flattening.
This is about this
question, this picture.
So we said, oh great, because
we can solve fold-and-cut,
we can also take the
boundary of that polygon
and flatten it like this.
Of course, the folding
of the interior here
which we're
ignoring-- in general,
this whole thing goes
through three dimensions
until we end up here.
One dimension up, if we solve
the 3D fold-and-cut problem
where you have a polyhedron,
you fold it through 4D
back into 3D which is
flat so that you align
all the boundaries of the
faces of that polyhedron.
And then just take the
boundary of that motion.
It's like flattening
a polyhedron
like cereal box or whatever.
And indeed, that will
find a folded state
of a polyhedron that is flat.
But of course, you can't
really use that motion,
because it goes through 4D.
This one will go
through 3D, so if you
want it to flatten this
linkage, that's also not valid.
So you get a folded
state, but you
don't get the
folding motion if you
could solve 3D fold-and-cut.
Our current state
is, we don't know
how to solve 3D fold-and-cut.
We do know how to solve
polyhedron flattening.
So this relation is
just kind of interest,
it doesn't imply
anything super useful.
An open problem
is, so we know how
to solve polyhedron
flattening as a folded state.
What we don't know so much
about is folding motions.
There is a recent paper
from just last year which
will continuously flatten
by continuous motion
any convex polyhedron.
But non convex polyhedron
we still don't know.
These are roughly
hand drawn figures.
An interesting project
would be to actually animate
their motion.
I think it would
look pretty cool
and be much more
convincing that it works.
I mean, I'm convinced
that it works,
but it's a lot harder to see
visually from these pictures.
It'd be really cool to see the
motions, the actual continuous
animation.
And a couple last project ideas.
One would be to make a
fold-and-cut alphabet,
like the maze software
that you just used.
It would be fun if you
just type in a message,
and out comes the
crease patterns.
This is sort of like a special
case of a fold-and-cut design
tool, but in letters
it's a little bit easier.
And a different challenge
would be if I just
want to be able to fold a
single letter at a time,
can you always do it
with simple folds?
So can you design
an alphabet that
is simply fold-and-cuttable.
That would be even nicer.
And there's some magicians
who worked on that,
but they couldn't
get all the letters,
so it would be nice to do with
just a few folds, any letter
of the alphabet, any digit.
This is one we did
for our conference
in honor of Martin Gardner,
gathering for Gardner five,
back in 2002.
And here's another possible
idea for a project,
although mostly it's
an excuse to show you
really cool pictures.
This is Peter Callesen,
and he takes usually
four sheets of paper, cuts
them probably an X-ACTO knife
or something, and then from
that material that he acquires,
builds a 3D structure
on that sheet.
So you see all the
material that was used,
and these are just amazing.
And I don't think you could
necessarily do this level
of fidelity from
a fold-and-cut ,
but it would be cool to do a
fold-and-cut and then build
a sculpture out of the
slits that you made.
And I mean, it's
really cool when
he can use the cutout parts
to be shadows of the things
that he builds, especially
when those shadows
are more complicated than the
sheet he actually assembles.
That's a fairly cool effect
of the monsters in the closet.
Pandora's box, or box
in a box in a box.
You can't see that here,
but you see it unfolding.
The bones inside the hand,
the old versus new cities.
Using the positive
and the negative.
There's actually a little boat
up there, which you can see.
So pretty amazing stuff.
And for free versus
caged, and so on.
Interesting project would
be to try to make art out
of fold-and-cut, just doing one
cut instead of a zillion cuts.
That's it.
Any more questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the
circle-packing method,
how do you assign the
mountain-valley [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE: OK,
in the circle-packing method,
how do you assign
mountains and valleys?
That was briefly
covered in lecture.
First you take a spanning
tree of all of the molecules,
and you basically
fold each molecule
into your parent in the tree.
So each one has a
direction, and from that
you can extract the
mountain-valley assignment.
You go into the parent.
It's a mountain there,
everyone else's valley.
Basically you're reversing
one perpendicular fold
per molecule.
I think.
Maybe two.
With triangles, it's just one.
For quads you might
be reversing two.
So you start with all
of the straight skeleton
being mountains, all the
perpendiculars being valleys,
and you have to flip a few to
just get them to fit together.
Little more complicated
than what I said,
but I would need a slide
to show you the details.
It's in the textbook.
Anything else?
All right, that's fold-and-cut.